we're glad to have Angela fan today with
us here um and she's um a research
scientist at meta AI research in New
York uh focusing on Research in text
generation mainly and currently she's
working on language modeling and
developing the line AI agents meta
products and Recent research products
include no language Left Behind which
she'll be talking briefly about today um
Universal speech translation for
Unwritten languages as well as llama too
um so give it up for Angela I
guess all right thank you all so much so
yeah I when I got this email I was like
oh I should probably talk about llama
too but then I noticed you have shiron
who will like you know is like a 10x
better speaker than me so I was like
okay like maybe not llama too but then I
thought I maybe would cover this project
that we did called No language Left
Behind which could be very uh also very
relevant to this class and so so when
you think about a lot of text generation
technology uh most of it until fairly
recently uh has been really focused on
English but there are actually more than
3,000 written languages worldwide and
for me this is extremely personally
meaningful because actually English is
my third language so it's really
important um yeah so it's really uh also
very personally meaningful and when you
think about some of the multilingual
technology that permeates it's not like
we've we've never worked on multilingual
right actually when speaking about
generative AI I actually think
translation is one of the most
commercially successful and widespread
applications of generative AI I mean
ultimately translation models they are
uh you know like conditional language
models and so when you think about like
traveling or something like that or my
sister is taking Spanish so like just
like doing her Spanish homework we have
a lot of tools that exist today so
things like Google translate cover
around 130 languages Microsoft translate
about 110 these might be a little bit
outdated since I pulled the statistics
um a little bit ago uh but the project
for no language left behind it started
from like a very simple ask like okay
there's 3,000 languages worldwide maybe
it'll be like pretty hard to get to all
3,000 since some of them are uh pretty
rare and not spoken by many but there
are still like hundreds of languages
spoken by millions and millions of
people and so we were like okay no big
deal like let's just start from the
100ish that we have today and just go
for like a doubling like what would it
take to actually be able to double this
kind of coverage and of course you know
just saying that you support a bunch of
languages is not the goal right like we
actually want to create high quality
safe translations that would be usable
by people just like if you're going on
vacation today your kind of instinct is
to whip out your phone and get on the
Google Translate
app and so kind of the backdrop to this
project was that there is actually a lot
of progress in translation so
historically there's been a lot of focus
on what we call higher resource
languages and these are not necessarily
languages that are spoken by the most
people in the world but when we say
higher resource it means the most amount
of data and so you can think about
things like europ parl or you know
translations from the European
Parliament and those served as the
foundation for a lot a lot of
translation development and more
recently there's been a great focus on
low resource languages and it's been
driven across the research Community
with groups like Ghana NLP masakane
America's NLP and these are all really
exciting developments and so these have
led to a lot of development of new data
sets as well as criticisms of existing
data sets and also work on new languages
and usually languages that people kind
of speak and they care a lot about and
we found this like really really
exciting and so looking at a lot of this
a bunch of us got together um at fair
and started thinking like okay we
actually speak some pretty low resource
languages from like catalon to Asam
and so on and so we started this as kind
of like a big passionate research
project and so today I want to cover a
little bit about our highle approach to
this problem which is a little bit
interdisciplinary I want to talk about
how we actually created the data sets to
be able to support this kind of work um
of course I want to talk about the
models since this is a class about
Transformers on one note here I think
that's actually very interesting in
terms of translation as like a research
direction is that actually a lot of
Innovations have been done in
translation and the original Transformer
paper I think is one of them and which
makes always translation a quite
interesting area to work on because I
feel like it's a it's a very mature
research area as well so it kind of is
like okay if your architecture Works in
Translation it probably works very
generally so that's also one of the
things that excites me about translation
research um then I want to talk about
evaluation like how are we actually
measuring and ensuring the quality of
these translations are good and safe for
people and then I want to end with a
little bit of like you know you know
High Lev thoughts about future
directions and things that I hope that
we can work on um in the future so I
want to start with our approach I think
the most important thing in research is
to know that we're working on a real
problem especially when it's really
close to people uh like translation and
I think in many areas like when I was
working on on device AI for example I
feel like I had like a research problem
in mind but it was like very very
disconnected from the Practical problem
of actually putting models on phones and
so this was something that was really
important to us and so we actually
started the project by uh kind of like
focusing on a social sciences type
approach or you know sociology type
approach and we actually did a lot of
interviews with low resource speakers
and so we met with about 44 different uh
native speakers that spoke 36 different
languages across North America um I will
say that a lot of them are like
immigrants to the us since that was kind
of like the easiest um kind of cohort to
recruit and we learned a lot of
different things about how they approach
low resource languages but also the kind
of technological need that they have
because I think it's easy to be like hey
I have this cool background like I have
this cool problem and I want to solve it
but I think it's very important to
actually like talk to the people this is
a problem that that needs to be solved
and so we learned that there's great
fear in general that low resource
languages might be undergoing a state of
decline partially because a lot of
education is Shifting to um languages
like Hindi or like English or or
Mandarin Chinese for example and there's
a lot of excitement to be included in
existing translation systems and people
said they have always tried to use uh
Google translator Microsoft translate um
in their existing languages But
ultimately they found that the quality
is really insufficient for Reliable
usage so if you think about like um well
I was going to say when I was in high
school but you all are probably like
substantially younger than me so maybe
like you know 10 so years ago you know
and you Tred to use Google Translate for
your Spanish homework like your Spanish
teacher could always identify that like
you know it was not a a human written
translation until you would get marks
off but that's not really the case for
some of the high resource languages
today and so I think as with all things
in machine learning it really starts
from a data perspective like why can't
we just train models in hundreds of
languages or large language models in
hundreds of languages it's because we
don't have the data to support it and so
I want to talk first about evaluation
data sets because I think it's extremely
important to nail evaluation um and then
I'll talk about
training so for an evaluation data set
for this work we started um this Flores
effort it stands for Facebook low
resource I guess we're called meta now
but I didn't think mes was like a very
good uh a renaming so we're still
calling it Flores so this was something
we originally started for just two
languages in this first paper at emnlp
um many years ago so it was just for
Nepali and sin Hollow and we later
extended it to incorporate two more
languages in a release afterwards you
know we we thought a lot about okay like
Flores was really useful for the
community
um how can we extend it to 100 languages
and so that was this follow-up work that
we did I think we had an ACL um or WMT
and then in this project we were like
okay how can we go from Flores 101 to
Flores 200 to really go for the doubling
effect and so what is Flores well it's
in the name it's a focus on low resource
languages so we do include some higher
resource languages like German or Hindi
or so on almost for calibration effect
as well but the majority of the focus is
on these lower and mid- resource
languages it's the first um large scale
many to many machine translation
evaluation data set which means that we
take all of the sentences in English and
then we translate them to all of the
languages which means that you would be
able to evaluate any cross pair of
languages so for example like Chinese to
French I I lived in France for many
years so it's like very personally
relevant to me of course 200 languages
also in the name there's a broad
diversity of different domains and
topics I think this is important when
designing an evaluation data set which
is like very top of mind for anybody
interested in in language modeling
research because like the way people
train machine translation models and the
way people use them are often like very
different and so if you only Benchmark
your data set for example on news which
is very common in Translation research
then you don't really pick up the fact
that people talk about such a wide
variety of things and have like
different casual conversations that they
need translated official documents and
so on it's also document level uh data
set this is not something that I think
the community is like broadly leveraging
right now but the way it's translated is
that you can have document level context
and so translators are provided the
entire document to translate from and we
also provide the entire document for
evaluation and we translate like
multiple sentences from the same
paragraph and so this was like a a
potential research direction that we
wanted to make sure we covered models
that needed like potentially more
context because a lot of translation
work is done at the sentence level so
how do we actually ensure that this data
set was high quality so the first step
is that we take a a document um well
actually first step is like alignment on
language standards so this is very
important because when you're
translating French or Chinese I think
most people have a strong understanding
of like what it means to produce like
good French or good Chinese and there
are a lot of professional translators
hired in these languages but when you go
to lower resource languages it's not
necessarily the case that there's like a
you know glowing translation industry
around translating um uh a lower
resource language and so one of the
first things is actually to align on
like what is a high quality translation
and so there's actually a lot of
challenges here so there are certain low
resource languages where there's
different competing language standards
or there's like very high variance uh in
different regions on how languages are
spoken and so this step is a pretty
critical one so then what we do is we
take the document we send it to one
group of translators and they do uh the
first translation step then we do some
automatic checking you know like if the
input sentence was like 10 words and the
output sentence like 300 words it's like
most likely something went wrong you
know and so we send it back otherwise uh
we'll send it onwards to a separate
completely independent set of
translators uh that do review and so
they try to rate the quality of this and
if the quality doesn't pass sufficient
bar and it gets s back to the original
set of translators to to edit and they
kind of go through and like address all
of the feedback and then if it's good
enough then it enters um our data set
and so there's many challenges here the
first one of course is just like finding
translators and also finding more
translators there was a certain uh issue
that we ran into for example that in a
certain country that the internet was
not available and so you know it's a lot
of recruitment the other one of course
is language standardization I think I
briefly mentioned this before but
there's a lot of different challenges in
um
just understanding like what is a high
quality translation for example the low
resource language Breton there's like
two competing groups on like how do you
write bretel so it's like very difficult
to resolve some of those things and the
final thing is that there's actually a
lot of variation even in languages like
Arabic like the Arabic like Moroccan
Arabic is very different from you know
Jordanian Arabic and so on and there are
also certain regions that they speak the
same language but due to historical
reasons they write in different Scripts
and so one of the things we actually did
was like if there are languages written
in multiple scripts we actually
supported the collection of in multiple
script evaluation and I think this is
really important because if if you're
building an underlying technology and
you only choose one then I think you
risk like just kind of like naturally
supporting one over the other um when we
we really should be like kind of a more
neutral technology provider and so this
is something that we we explored a lot
as well as exploring different variants
of
Arabic uh this is also open source if
you just go go to this link you can just
like download all of the all of the text
files uh for this with evaluation done I
want to talk a little bit about how we
collected some of these training data
sets the first thing I want to talk
about is this data set we created called
NLB seed and the idea of this is like
it's a really seed data set of high
quality translations and languages that
really don't have anything why because
well you can't start from nothing you
know you got a bootstrap from somewhere
a lot of people have been using the
Bible uh as a way to bootstrap but it's
very uh limited domain obviously very
religious text and so we created this
data set n lob seed for languages that
really don't have um anything to get
started from it's only about 5,000
sentences so it's nothing crazy but it
supports a lot of different use cases
like training language identification
models or sentence encoders uh engram
language models like all of these things
that I'm about to talk about in our data
set
pipeline um so it covers 43 languages
about 6,000 sentences and the way we
decide to sample is it is focused on
really General content so Wikipedia has
this article of like hey if you're going
to start like a new Wikipedia in your
new language I think Wikipedia has like
39ish wikipedias last I checked um
here's like a list of articles that
every Wikipedia in a new language should
have and so that's where we sampled this
original content from and of course it's
also uh open source if you if you want
to download it so what we ended up doing
to get large scale training data is
using mining so this is not something we
pioneered in this project we have like a
bunch of different previous work so we
started from wiky Matrix we were like
hey there's a lot of different sentences
in Wikipedia and different languages
that we should be able to match up and
so we tried to do that with Wikipedia to
get machine uh TR translation training
data we extended that to the web in the
CC Matrix project and then we extended
it to very very large scale mining on
all cross pairs in this project on
Beyond English Centric multilingual
machine translation where really try to
ditch like English as a central pivot
language and so the way this whole data
mining thing works is that it focuses on
sentence alignment so everyone is
probably super familiar with this
because this how language models are
built now it's like you take common craw
or any other open source dump of the web
I don't know like red pajama or like
whatever you want to ccnet whatever you
want to use these days and you uh take
all of the data you extract all of the
text you know a lot of HTML parsing and
so on goes into it and the idea is that
we want to try to find matching text
that could be a translation so we
shatter it all into sentences we embed
them with different sentence encoder
models and then we do a match to try to
understand in a multilingual space if
the sentences
match and so one of the biggest
challenges to this is that the quality
of the sentence encoding is very
important so if your sentence encoding
is not very accurate then it's
impossible to match in this
multi-dimensional space the idea of like
the meaning being the same and so one of
the big things we tried to do here in
this project was try to improve the
quality of the sentence encoders um and
so one of the big things that we did was
train sentence encoders with mass
language modeling you see that on the
left but we also use multilingual
distillation which you see on the right
and so previous approaches uh to
sentence encoders and the trend in the
research Community for a while was to
really try to embed all languages in the
same sentence encoder model so projects
like xlm R for example are in that
direction I think is pretty widely used
uh the challenge with this when you're
training a low resource model is that a
lot of your high resource data it just
overwhelms your your low resource data
and so you don't end up with a very high
quality sentence incoder for those
languages so what we ended up doing is
we had a multilingual teacher model and
we distilled a bunch of student models
that are specialized to different
language families uh that are low
resource and so this enables the quality
to be pretty high and so the way the
distillation works is that the teacher
and the student model both see the same
data and then we try to U minimize the
cosine loss between the sentence
embeddings that they uh produce I think
an important question that you can ask
here is like why do you need to do
multilingual distillation like why can't
you just train a bunch of different
student models like one per language
family like why even care about
distillation and the reason is because
if you're going to use a bunch of
sentence and for mining the important
thing is that they all exist in the same
embedding space you know like if you
train one separate model and another
separate model there's nothing
constraining them so that you can mine
all of the data against each other and
so one of the things we found is that by
starting everything from the same
teacher model and trying to use this
cosine loss to minimize the distance
between embeddings you are able to have
this constrained space where you can
mine every language against every other
even if you have different student
models and so this uh graph on the Y AIS
it shows the error rate of of Mining and
so lower is better and on the x-axis it
shows a bunch of different low resource
languages so for example the first one
is uru the second one is uh Telugu third
one is Tagalog and so on and so the gray
bar here is the original laser paper so
this is a paper we put out maybe in 2018
is and we had all of these languages
with count of them as included but as
you can see the error rate is extremely
extremely high for these languages so
even though they were included couldn't
really be used for high quality and the
blue bar is the laser model that we
trained based on the technique I just
described in the previous slide and you
can see that I think the most important
point is that you can barely see the
blue bars so it was very effective even
for these previous languages that people
had thought we had like previously um
embedded and then so now how does this
kind of thing fit into a whole data
pipeline around this approach so one of
the most important things
is like when you download the data from
the web you don't really know what
language it's in and so this is part of
like all of the large scale data
cleaning that goes into like you know
training large language models today and
so the way we identify different
languages is through like simple
classification models called language ID
identification models and I think it's a
classification model and so people think
it's easier than it actually is but I
think some of the major challenges are
that there's so many different languages
uh they're written in many different
ways and web text is very casual and so
it can be very difficult to actually
train a good classification model that
can generalize to that and so what we
did is you know we had our uh liid
training data and we produced uh a
language identification model liid and
then we actually did human evaluation to
label errors coming from the liid system
to iteratively improve this on web text
itself to improve the quality of of this
specific model then after we produce
this Li model then we insert like all of
our common craw where the web arrow is
coming in and we do a ton of filtering
and cleaning and this produces a huge
Corpus of different monolingual data
that you can then use for for training
anything afterwards uh we train our
encoder the what I described on the
previous text and then we convert this
monolingual data into what we call Mind
by texts so these are a huge data set of
things that we think are translations of
each other um and then find what we do
is we actually try to validate that
these are real mind B texts by training
very small bilingual multilingual uh
sorry bilingual translation models in
order to see you know what the quality
is like and I think this is important
because like the data development cycle
and like the end task that it's being
used for uh you you don't want to you
know like completely separate it an
analogy to large language model training
today is that like when you're doing
your pre-training uh you don't want like
someone to just deliver you a data like
the data mix of your different data sets
is very important and it's pretty uh
similar
here and I think one of the highlights
that we that we did here is really like
focused on the human evaluation of the
language identification model because
that actually improves the quality of
like all of the underlying data if you
just like more accurately know what
language it's
in and this entire data pipeline is
actually open sourced in this library
and we had an emlp paper describing it
the reason why I thought this was
important is that because like I think
data cleaning is actually such a
fundamental underlying thing that drives
model quality and people's data
pipelines you know it's like I have this
script and this other thing and that
this other thing and so it's actually I
think very important to be able to
recreate it and rerun it um as part of
you know almost like your your research
uh that you would do um as follow-up
work and so that's why we open sourced
them a few reflection
things for low resource languages even
though we did a a large scale mining I
think monolingual data is the limiting
factor like there are many languages
that do not have like a huge amount of
text written online and so it can be
very challenging to get a large amount
further I think languages and unique
scripts can be extremely hard to get
good representations of if you don't
have very much data um there are certain
languages as well where they were
historically written in a new script but
now the government would like to write
it um in a totally new one like the old
cheeky script for example and so there's
not a lot of content uh to represent
these scripts so it's hard to learn
representations and then further a lot
of the content we create it's even after
mining it's a fairly limited domain
often religious
content okay so uh with data discussed I
want to segue a little bit into into
some of the modeling work just to kind
of start with like a highlevel picture I
think there's like three major
challenges when you talk about like
large scale multilingual modeling and
these pretty much apply
um to language models as
well the first one is effective data
augmentation for low resource languages
like how can you prevent the low
resource language data from just being
completely drowned out by the time
you've seen like all of your words of
German or Russian I think there's also a
question of like scalability of the
model so even if you train very large
scale models how do you prevent the
representations of different languages
from interfering with each other and
that leads to the last Point as well of
like you give the model very limited
capacity then of course it may not have
the capacity to model all of these
different languages and so you also need
to accelerate uh the scale of the model
and so preliminary for for those uh who
may not have seen a translation system
before I don't know how many of you that
practically is um so we use standard
sequence to sequence models so the input
text the like Coral thing is like what
you want to translate enters a
Transformer decoder model um that then
you know with attention mechanism goes
to a Transformer decoder model and then
it decodes autor regressively the actual
translation which you can see here in
yellow and so I want to talk a little
bit about like how uh the data looks as
we feed it into the models so there's a
few different ways that you might want
to think about data so you want to be
like okay did a human look at it and
decide that like these two sentences are
translations or are they noisy also is
it is it limited in size another thing
you can think about is like is the data
quality depending on some other factor
and so that's like the model dependent
thing in which case like the data
quality may be capped by the quality of
that dependency um and so I think you
could think a little bit like the ideal
data set it would be like humans have
reviewed you know every bit of it it's
not noisy at all we have an infinite
amount and it doesn't have any
dependencies on any other models it's
just like pure quality but in reality
like closer to what we have are these so
we have a bunch of different data
sources we have the seed data that I
discussed like way back in the talk
where it's a small amount of like really
high quality human Align data but the
only problem is that it's limited in
size it's like 6,000 sentences per
language we have the public by text so
this is data that people have created
over many years of working on
translation you know you can download it
from like the Opus uh Corpus for
example mostly has not been reviewed by
humans so pretty extremely noisy in many
languages it's just coming from the
Bible so the size is quite Lim
you have our mind
data uh so this is not human aligned
either um and but it does have a model
dependency you know it's dependent on
the quality of the sentence encoders and
we have two other sources of data uh
from back translation so the idea of
back translation it's a model
augmentation technique heavily used in
machine translation where you use a
model to produce like pseudo
translations like silver data um and we
use two different techniques to produce
these back translations that also are
dependent on the underlying model used
to used to make the translations so this
is a picture of like our high level
different data sources and like how you
want to think about the quality and the
different axes and so if we put them all
together what do we get so the y- axis
here is the number of training Pairs and
the x-axis here is the languages sorted
by resource so you can see like on the
on the left hand side you have your low
resource languages like wof and on your
uh right hand side you've got your high
resource languages like French uh the
peak is is English of course and so if
you just look at what's available
publicly this is a distribution you get
and you'll see like a huge huge fallof
pretty quickly and then if you add in
the data that we have created for Mining
and back translation our goal is
basically to like make the distribution
a little bit more uniform it's very hard
on the extremely low resource side uh of
course but to make it a little bit more
uniform so that you don't just
immediately you know overfit on your low
resource languages before you you've
even seen like three shards of your
German
data with that kind of data strategy in
mind I want to talk a little bit about
mixt mixture of experts so this is
something that we explored quite uh
aggressively in the translation space
for a number of years um you know we
could have this equal conversation about
some of the debates going on on like do
you want sparse or DSE architectures for
large language models uh but essentially
mixture of experts it enables massive
scale because you don't have to just
scale like your kind of your dense trunk
model uh but you can have like a bunch
of different separate experts that you
activate per token um it also allows you
to avoid language interference because
the idea is that the different experts
they could specialize to specific
languages um unfortunately it adds a ton
of capacity so it becomes pretty easy uh
to overfit so I want to talk a little
bit about this overfitting phenomenon so
the top set set of graphs that we're
going to talk about is for the language
um Congo and then the bottom set of
languages is French so you really want
to compare like a low resource language
on top with a high resource language on
bottom so if you just take your dense
model traditional Transformer sequence
to sequence architecture that's this
graph that you're showing right so
there's a little bit of overfitting on
the low resource language but you can
pretty much regularize this with
standard Dropout techniques right so
there's not a big problem and on French
you know you you basically have no real
problem however the minute you switch
from like a dense architecture to a
token level Moe architecture uh you just
experience massive overfitting on the
low resource language so the the green
line here is like just demonstrating
without Dropout the overfitting and then
if you add Dropout you know you get a
little bit better performance but it's
still overfitting quite a bit like
essentially by like you know 12K updates
you know there's there's no real point
in continuing training like you're
burning GPU basically um and so one of
the things we actually worked on quite a
bit was like trying to to figure out how
to properly regularize thesee
architectures with this uh specific
masking technique on on the gating
function that decides like whiche to
route to sorry which expert to route to
in youre architecture to just try to
pull back some of this overfitting
effect so if you look in the in the top
uh right graph the purple line you know
you still see some uh you know
successful
regularization another thing that we did
to control uh the overfitting effect
it's actually quite being used in um
language models today as well is
curriculum learning and the idea of this
is like how are we going to Stage when
languages are introduced and so what we
did was we tried to train a vanilla
model and then we started to measure
when the languages begin to overfit and
then we basically bucket them did them
into different sections and so for high
resource languages like French you want
to start it early and it needs to be
trained the entire way but for a lower
resource language like w you know after
maybe like 100K updates it's done so the
rest of the time is just overfitting and
so it actually gets worse the more you
train it so what we did is we moved some
of those lower resource languages and we
inserted them much later into the
training schedule so you start training
your high resource then you start
training your low your mid resource and
then your low resource and then you're
very low resource and so by the end you
know everything in theory has trained
and is not as overfit as it would be
without this kind of
technique so I want to show some results
so first I want to show results on
existing data sets so before we get to
200 languages like let's just talk about
100 languages and so this is the Flores
101 Dev test it's important to compare
to this because this is where like
existing benchmarks in the community lie
um whereas on 200 of course we can put
up anything you know because it's the
first work on that so the First Column
is uh translating out of English so
English to Chinese English to Icelandic
anything like that the second column is
translating into English so Chinese to
English the third column XX y y is
translating any cross pair not involving
English and the last column is the
average so if you look at the first set
of rows this is a comparison on models
that cover 87 different languages so
there was this paper MTM 100 there was
also this deep net paper so you can see
the average blue score blue is a
standard translation metric essentially
metric of word overlap um so we're
looking at Blue score here and so you
can see the last row N lb 200 um even
though we cover 200 languages the blue
score is substantially uh above some of
the existing work now if we look at 101
languages only the Delta LM paper from
Microsoft at the time covered that uh
number of languages and so if you
compare on all of the different cross
sets uh similarly you see that this no
language Left Behind model is um much
stronger in terms of blue one thing
really quick on the variance of these
blue numbers I think it's important to
understand like is something statistic
Al significant or not I think about 0.5
blue is kind of like the the general
like plus minus that you'll see and so
if it's like above that you'll it's
usually a statistically significant
metric Improvement okay so now I want to
talk a little bit about floor as 200
results so here similar like the first
chunk of columns translating out of
English then like next chunk is
translating into English then you have
like your cross Pairs and then you have
your average um so we have this blue
metric as well we also have a character
level metric um based on CHR f++ that's
commonly used in the translation
community so I think looking at these
numbers of course like there's no
Baseline work to compare to on like on
the previous slide and so you know when
we get to human evaluation in a little
bit it'll be more concrete but I think
generally one of the kind of rules of
some I have for these types of numbers
is like around 30 is like pretty pretty
reasonably becomes uh usable um and I
think another thing like if you compare
these supervised um pairs to zero shot
pairs I think we don't see like a huge
drop off on zero shot which indicates
the model has like some sort of
generalization even if it didn't see
that translation pair uh directly during
training another way to to calibrate
some of this is to compare to Google
Translate and so if you compare to
Google translate um no language Left
Behind is quite a bit better at
translating um into English and not as
good as translating out of English
although if you like average across
everything um it's a little bit
better I want to talk a little bit about
human evaluation as well to complement
some of our discussion on automatic
evaluation and so I think you know
automatic metrics fast really good for
research iteration uh impossible to move
forward without but human evaluation uh
is really the the real deal here and so
we had this paper at AMTA um on how to
make this human evaluation very
consistent and scalable across different
language pair
I think this goes back to the kind of
evaluation data set point that I was
making at the beginning of the talk
where you know if you're a professional
German translator you're really good at
evaluating the quality of your German
translation um but beyond that you know
there's not a lot of consistency and if
you evaluate translation on like a fiveo
scale you know like a five translating
between two languages and like a three
translated between other two languages
like are those really comparable and so
we had this entire experiment method
ology on how we might want um to make
this a little bit more
comparable so I want to show some
results now on this so the Y AIS here so
the metric is called xsts a metric for
how we're doing this human evaluation
the y- axis here is actually the
Delta uh so anything you know it's a
fivepoint scale so it's it's a Delta not
the raw score um the x-axis here is a
bunch of different translation
directions that we evaluated so the gray
set is translating into English the
green set is translating non-english
directions so like uh French to wof and
then the blue set is translating out of
English and so what you're looking for
is like a positive Delta indicates that
um our modeling architecture is much
better so the what the Delta is between
is like a a baseline Transformer model
just trained on all of our data versus
like the final no language Left Behind
model that we created
so the data is actually the same for
both of them that's how we get all 200
languages um so we're just measuring
here the human eval of the modeling
improvements and so you can see most of
the Delta is pretty um pretty noticeable
um some of them not so much like um you
know I don't know Zulu to English we
didn't seem to improve very much but in
general like it's a Improvement
detectable by human evaluation you might
also ask like okay what is the
statistically significant difference
here between about 0.2 to 0.3 plus or
minus is something that's like uh pretty
noticeable and like above 0.5 it's it's
very
noticeable one of the things that I also
want to get at in evaluation is that
there's many different um facets of
model evaluation and I think if you look
at like all of the different like llm
leaderboards or like the transparency
reports or whatever you like begin to
internalize this pretty quickly but what
we just looked at are just like very
highlevel summary num numers and they
don't really tell you like what exactly
are the errors and like is It ultimately
usable by people is it like a safe thing
that people can rely on and so one of
the things we really focused on is uh
user safety and some of that manifests
in um some of the toxicity work that we
did and the driving thing here is that
like not all errors in Translation are
made equal so during covid there was
this one that was like really went viral
circulating around but the message
during Co is like you got to wash your
hands but the translation produc is like
you got to hold hands which I think is
like exactly the opposite of of what you
want to do and other types of
measurement errors are are really
important as well so if you're like
telling someone how far they want to go
and you're like hey you want to travel
like five kilometers and then your
translation is like travel 500
kilometers you know it's a completely
different type of issue and so what we
did for toxicity which is a big Focus
for this work is that we collected
different toxicity lists for all 200
languages and so why do I care so much
about toxicity I think it's a it's a
user safety thing so if you input like
some perfectly benign text and then the
output is profanity I think it's just
like really unexpected and it breaks a
lot of trust in the system and it's an
extremely poor experience for people
that that being said it's also a very
very challenging thing because it's
extremely culturally specific so things
that are slurs or you know insults in
certain languages They Don't Really
generalize across cultures which means
that things like this are uh very
challenging to create and I also was
very interested in this direction
because I think it's broadly useful for
all sorts of different type of uh
detection uh things that you need to do
and also mitigation and so even though
we developed this in the context of
translation it can be used very broadly
in other types of NLP
applications um this is also open source
you can download it you have to type in
a little password U that's uh in the
GitHub repo just so that you don't
accidentally like download and realize
you have files of like curse words all
over all over your
computer okay so I want to end a little
bit with some thoughts about future
directions U and before I get there like
you know there's like a 190 page paper
uh that like writes up like all of this
in far greater detail um in case you're
you're
curious so a few future directions that
I think I'm really interested in and
some of these like are also very
applicable to things like speech is that
I think one of them is more explicit
multi multilingual so I think a lot of
approaches to multilingual have been
like hey you know we have this thing
it's working well for one language like
let's try to scale it to a bunch of
different languages and then we're going
to put them all in the same modeling
bucket and just kind of like hope that
the model learns all of these different
representations but I think there's a
lot of potential room for explicitly
bringing in like the fact that you know
it's multilingual into the
architecture um more and so you know
it's possible to capture more nuances
between languages or different
relationships between languages um the
other one is continued support for
everyone I think it's like something
reflecting on this project is that you
know going from 100 to 200 was already
pretty challenging but going Beyond a
lot of the techniques that we developed
here are not necessarily that scalable
um this is actually what inspired some
of our work on speech translation as
well so if you recently saw like the
seamless m4t release or like the
unwritten languages like we did a lot of
modeling of hokan and I think that goes
into the this direction really well
because many of the languages that
people uh want to use are like spoken
first languages and not necessarily like
primarily
written and then I think the last thing
that I'm still really passionate about
is like continued increased ease of use
and training of these models and like
democratization for the community so one
of the things that we try to do in this
work is just like really really clearly
write down everything that we did and
like open source like even the data
Pipeline and things like that and so
that's where you get like all of the
repos that I linked and um you know like
a huge write up but I think if someone
were to try to reproduce this for their
own language and many people have like
I'm not saying that that hasn't been but
it's like if you wanted to like do this
it would be extremely extremely hard um
because there's like so much different
uh things going on so I think most of
the what we've seen is like people have
downloaded the base model and fine tuned
it for their own language but it's
pretty hard to just like add on um many
many more languages to the system
because of how complicated all the
moving parts are and so I feel like
something for the translation Community
overall is like how do how do we
simplify a lot of these things and I
think that's where like a lot of
fundamental modeling uh Innovation uh
could help us get to and so yeah I got a
chance to give this talk but of course
the work is like being done by a a huge
team of people that I've cited here
um and yeah if you want to uh use any of
this or read more about it like
everything is linked from this main
GitHub repo here um in Fair seek and you
can like click on everything else
afterwards um but yeah maybe maybe I'll
go back to Stephen um if we have any
questions or anything else like that
right no thanks for the great talk yeah
if anybody has any questions feel free
to unmute and
ask
uh did you consult with a lot of like
native speakers um for like you know
profanities and this type of stuff like
how are you able to get access to the um
you know lowquality languages or low
resource languages and make sure the
translations are correct yeah yeah
that's a really good question I mean I
think it's the most important to consult
like a bunch of native speakers um
across the entire development process so
part of our original thing was just like
interviewing a bunch of people to
understand like what they're looking for
for in a high quality translation and
then we have like an entire uh
professional translation team hired
which took quite a long time to find um
to to consult with along along um the
process and then right now like we also
have some of the things like toxicity
lists are open to the community so if
you make like a poll request we try to
like you know validate that it's like a
a useful addition and then like try to
merge it in um as
well
we have a question in the room let's see
if it comes over soon goe I'll speak
see so like do you spend most of your
time in the data pipeline stage um
yeah yeah yeah a good question um I
think the question is did you spend most
of your time in the data pipeline state
it ended up being about like kind of
like 5050 like uh data or more like uh
driving work and then like 50/50 on on
the the other side like modeling and
evaluation work because once like the
data is set then there is a lot and lot
of iteration on the modeling side to
figure out like okay which how much of
the data should we use like how should
we portion the data how do we prevent
overfitting what is the right
architecture um but a lot of work goes
into the data because I think if you
don't have high quality data you know
you you just can't get a good
model and for data mining how do you
mind the data do you use like selenium
or how do you mind the web
um yeah so for the web we start with
common craw um so we downloaded all of
the different dumps of common crawl and
then we use um HTML parser I think now
like you know if you download for
example the red pajama data set like
they've done a lot of this like parsing
and stuff um and then we have like large
scale uh pipelines that are set up like
you can use spark for example um to
process these things to like split all
of the different sentences out run your
language identification you know you can
do different heuristic cleaning um there
are certain languages where it's like
very actually very challenging to
identify what is a sentence like I think
in Thai there is no like period so you
have to like use uh different models to
identify what is a sentence and like
parse some of those things out um and
then we end up with you know our
monolingual uh data
dump what is Comm Crow is it software
that you use for data oh yeah yeah
common crawl is kind of like a an open
source version of the web that that runs
I think maybe quarterly I would have to
check but yeah if you go to like common
craw.org you can download it but warning
it's like um very
large hey I have a question um you might
have mentioned this briefly but I'm
wondering how chat gbt and gb4 does on
this um like just just does just more
scale and pre-training data help as well
for um low resource U machine
translation
yeah yeah good question actually there
have been some studies done on like how
you know these systems work I think for
high resource languages it's actually
quite beneficial um to scale up I think
part of that is because the models have
some innate generalization and so one of
the challenges that people talk about
different things in different languages
so like seeing that knowledge in another
language can actually help the
generalization but on low resource
languages it's um yeah the performance
is pretty difficult um especially on
some of of these translation benchmarks
I also think that language models in
terms of being trained for like a
translation objective tend to score
worse on translation benchmarks because
language models are like approximately
capturing the same thing whereas
translation models you like really try
to align the meaning a little bit more
um but yeah so I think for low resource
still pretty challenging um but yeah one
one thing that's interesting is uh for
most English language models they can
actually do a reasonable job at
producing other languages because it's
impossible to get rid of other languages
in your English specific data so things
like French or German will work
reasonably so just to clarify you said
language models trained with a
translation
objective do better right
because they tend to do better like if
you fine- tune for the translation task
uh it it will tend to do better that
makes sense compared to like for example
some few shot um in context examp poster
right right exactly exactly and one
other question
is
um do you see this being similar to for
example fine tuning on particular expert
domains which might also have
um less data and low resource and as
well as domain specific jargon and so
forth
um yeah I mean I think if we were to
restart this project now I think that
would be one of the first things we also
explored at least like an extremely
strong Baseline where if you like take
some of the data and you try to
fine-tune um or you know try to do
domain adaptation I think that's also
where like some of the like retrieval
type approaches uh go in for you know
translation but also large language
modeling work where you try to have like
a separate domain that you can like
retrieve some text in for adaptation I
think all of those approaches are pretty
promising oh great any other questions
one quick one on the point ofil on one
of the slides I think you showed some
Peak results with zero shot that were
higher than um just the base model do
you think that's because there might
still be some overfitting on those slow
resource languages yeah good question so
for our large scale mining we don't mind
like every single possible cross pair so
like like Icelandic wof
it's probably like not like the most
inand translation Direction and so we
did not mind like all 200 times 200
because it's like really producing like
a combinatorial explosion and so that's
where the zero shot results come from
where you know you don't need uh we
don't have training data D directionally
in that pair but the model has seen both
the input and the output and so I think
those results are pretty good in well
they're good for certain langu languages
which I think goes to show like the
generalization capability
um and it's not like as critical to have
like every single pair covered but many
of them are are not as good and so you
see overall the performance is lower
even though on certain languages it can
perform better than you expect but
that's because it has seen the input and
the output it's not zero shot on like
completely unseen
language I have a
question I wanted do you also you know
do something related to transcription or
audio
information yeah good question so in
this project no not so much
transcription but we had a follow-up
work that we released actually just like
a month or or so ago uh called seamless
m4t which is like a joint model for both
speech and text translation and that's
where we do leverage a lot of audio
transcription because that also has like
the it helps us Bridge you know like the
spoken data and the text data to
leverage both of them
together wait just to clarify the
supervised fine tuning it worked better
right compared to um other
methods uh so actually in this work it
was as a couple years ago now so
supervised fine tuning wasn't H as
common as it it was now but I think in
the literature if you want to use like a
large language model to do translation
it's currently best yet if you do some
supervised fine tuning I'm I'm just
wondering about that because the way as
humans right we don't
just learn by looking at pairs of the
same thing in different languages and
kind of memorizing how to map from one
to the other uh we kind of learn in a
more unsupervised way where if we know
both languages then we can kind of
naturally translate between them
um but I guess it makes sense for an llm
why having supervis supervised examples
would help you yeah I mean I think as
like the the base Foundation model
continues to improve in quality I think
that's where the quality will probably
improve when you don't need less and
less fine tuning I mean I think that's
like the open AI approach like if you
have the best foundation model then you
don't need as much like domain specific
fine tuning and I think like you know
like at the start when I started working
on text generation there was like
translation researchers and like
summarization researchers and like
question answering researchers and they
like work very differently but now it's
like it's all driven by the same
underlying thing and you're not like a
specialized summarization researcher uh
anymore right I think that's that makes
a lot of
sense do we have any other
questions come on any more inperson
questions don't think so okay great all
right well thank you Angela for the very
interesting and a great talk again um
and for taking the time and we hope um
yeah we hope that you can keep in touch
and if anybody has any other questions
feel free to um get in touch with Angela
all right thanks so much for having me
today bye
everyone